émile gaudreault derrière vous louis
josé houde
c'est votre arme de destruction massive
en humour ce absolument il m'a jamais
son coup merci au revoir le josé autres
il détruit tout parce que vous avez fait
avec lui le père en flic d'affaires
affleck 2 est le menteur vrai sens de
l'humour oui hélas fort selon selon
selon vous de nos jeunes
ben c'est un génie c'est aussi simple
que est un génie de la comédie c'est le
letton est un surdoué un charisme
absolue est extrêmement drôle et à
mesure qu'il prend l'expérience c'est
aussi là le grand acteur dramatique
qu'il est se révèle donc et il ya aussi
cette qualité là qu'on s'identifie à lui
est un vrai leading man comment juger
quelqu'un qui peut porter une histoire
parce que on s'en fait pour lui ça y'en
a pas de temps que seuls les gens la
maison qui auront reconnu autre visage
avait commencé que le groupe sanguin
donc sur cinq
ouais s qu'encore aujourd'hui vous
utilisez certains procédés humoristique
a pris par le groupe s'engage à offrir
tous les jours de tournage à chaque
seconde de tournage
j'utilise je fête mes chaussures fin
avec entre autres marie lise pilote et
dany turcotte son livre est vrai comique
j'ai tout absorber tous les jours quand
je suis devant une scène avec lui josé
avec antoine avec des acteurs locaux on
essaie d'avoir 7 5 2 je pense que la
capacité de dire ok c'est drôle je pense
que vient de sémiologie fait avec ces
gens là je sais pas d'où ça m'aiderait
autrement que ce mais je pense que
j'étais faite pour ça mais moi je
passais bien utile celui là trente ans
plus tard
trente ans plus tard j'ai bâti cette
entrevue leçon de cinéma sans heurt avec
émile gaudreault
ok on sait qu'il ya pas de recette
magique un humour pour faire un bon
blockbuster mais quand même quels sont
les ingrédients gagne moi honnêtement
l'ariana une recette une recette essaie
d'être profondément conscients qu'ils
aient pas de recette
c'est à dire que la partie du moment où
je dois penser que j'ai une touche
magique parce que j'ai fait des films
qui ont fonctionné et que je veux
m'asseoir là dessus c'est fini je suis
profondément convaincu seulement une
façon d'y arriver c'est de ré
cliché de travail et d'attendre
l'inspiration de recommencer de
recommencer il doit recommencer encore
et conscience profonde locke à quel
point ces fragiles excès l'échec est pas
loin toujours une google google
donc ça pour moi c'est celle servent à
cela c'est que je me pose je terrifiée à
l'idée de pour réussir à mettet a amené
cette histoire le gabon par les
critiques m'importe peu mais certains de
vos fans qui ont été traduits à
l'étranger avec succès box-office
incroyable au québec il ya eu deux beaux
femmes par contre au moins bien
fonctionné le sens de l'humour
le vrai du faux c'est à peut-être des
échecs on va tous signés
comment est drôle qui va être la vedette
dans son pick le sens de l'humour je me
fais de 3.4 millions au box office way
point de vue critique statec mois
réussis
c'est un film que j'ai vingt minutes de
ce film que je trouve extraordinaire et
c'est un film que j'ai raté la deuxième
je rate un peu ma faim et j'ai pas
réussi à trouver la fin de cette
histoire là mais il ya un moment dans ce
film là que je trouve quand on aime on
enseigne à michel côté comment être
drôle que c'est une chose
benoît brière où je suis très fier de
cette partie si le sujet c'est comme une
espèce de les virtuoses s'est dit le
douanier unique et son montage l'adidas
mais c'est vrai que c'est un film que
avec du recul est ce un film aussi qui
contribue à ce que je sois terrifié que
l'on a fait d'autres la suite c'est un
film qui avait une fille qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui ressemble à un saint
superficiellement mais qui avait pas une
fin et motive c'est c'est peut-être pour
ça que ce film n'a pas été reçue au
temps mais que j'ai reçu trois offres de
faire un remake en france aux etats-unis
1 a refait le film quand même que des
gens qui cette idée là en tout cas
quitté pape que j'ai pas abouti c'est un
jeu j'en suis conscient mais c'est
idées-là d'enseigner la comédie à
quelqu'un qui est un peu psychopathe
j'y crois encore beaucoup ces jours ci à
leur faire encore nettement pour nous le
réussir cette fois le autant films
populaires autant de comédies
lyon parce que faire une comédie au
québec qui ne fonctionne pas c'est comme
si tu avais besoin d'enfant c'est les
comédies que pour fonctionner on en
parle encore les comédies qui à 20 ans
qui n'ont pas fonctionné
on les nomme encore les mentionne encore
et donc j'ai fait exprès une conscience
quand même d'un danger de tu peux
devenir presque un paria s'ouvre est une
comédie ici le milieu du cinéma les
critiques que c'est
c'est vraiment un carnage je sais et je
trouve cela dommage parce qu'on devrait
il devrait avoir plein de jeunes dans ce
moment qui font des comédies qui se
trompent qui en font depuis qu'il fait
et on sait qu'on crie pas cette ambiance
là en ce moment tous que vous avec les
institutions qui sont frileuses on
dirait que le milieu du cinéma se disent
c'est pas important
[Musique]
- mails godeau merci beaucoup merci à
toi
[Musique]